foreign
ghost ships
oil Traders
Casino operators
North Korean spies
a gold Trader from Hong Kong
and a racing car driver from a cow
there have been some arrests a few
suicides
in this joint investigation with the
Royal United Services Institute think
tank in London we reveal for the first
time some of the faces behind the
organized criminal networks that have
facilitated North Korean sanctions of
Asia North Korea has been using the
Triads and others to assist it in its
operations it's had to procure oil
illicitly and the end result is that the
weapons program keeps going
no matter what they will find oil to
fuel themselves what we found again and
again were connections to the casinos
connections to Sun City these weaknesses
in the Global Financial system are
exploited by a whole range of illicit
actors so the ability to launder money
is critical for North Korea's weapons
program this is a country whose
ballistic missiles can reach Halfway
Around the Globe the Triads and these
high-level criminal organizations
they're a strategic concern for all of
us
this is a story about how the Triads
facilitate the oil trade that keeps
North Korea's weapons program alive
without oil and without oil products
like petrol and especially diesel not
only the North Korean economy but also
its very large military upon which the
regime bases its power would simply
grind to a halt
[Music]
my name is James Byrne and I'm the
director of Open Source Intelligence and
Analysis of the royal United Services
Institute in London I've been working on
this investigation for over a year we've
been tracking North Korea's illicit
Imports of oil trying to identify the
individuals the entities Behind These
Imports and how North Korea is evading
U.N security Council resolutions and
this brings us to the story of a ship
called the Unica the Unica is really one
of the key parts of this story because
it is the tanker that the North Koreans
have been able to rely on to regularly
deliver fuel to North Korea they have
continued to do it despite all of the
sanctions despite patrols which are
conducted by a range of countries it has
been operating in the East China Sea for
a long time and it's continued to do it
from the Waters of Taiwan where it meets
intermediary tankers tankers that load
oil from those ports and then it
shuttles that oil regularly to North
Korea where it is picked up by North
Korean tankers and moved into the port
foreign
they try to use other methods not to be
seen so they do the ship to ship
transfer in the evening or midnight or
the area that's usually the ships are
not supposed to anchor down
now these vessels can't be tracked they
go dark the vessels are almost ghost
vessels they live at sea without going
into port for months at a time
my name is Hugh Griffiths for five years
I was coordinator of the UN panel of
experts monitoring the sanctions on
North Korea
boarding North Korean ships are you the
Radio Room operator where are your
communication log books meeting with
bank Executives inspecting seized arms
from shipping containers witnessing the
destruction of North Korean weapons that
sort of thing Even in our early
investigations we found that the foreign
flag tanker meeting with the North
Korean tanker would be conducting
dialogue using WeChat and that code was
used and that you only knew you were
meeting the right ship because a remimbi
note which had been torn into the
supplier ship the captain of that vessel
would have one half of the note and the
true ship he was meant to meet to supply
fuel to would have the other half of the
note
foreign
it is only by finding out who is moving
the oil to North Korea that allows us to
prevent them doing it in order to
understand how North Korea procures
these oil products one first needs to
understand the methods through which
over decades it has used irregular and
illicit channels to raise money all of
our efforts to enforce sanctions to
ultimately bring North Korea to the
table should also focus on seeing North
Korea really as you know a criminal
organization but with connections to
high-level organized crime figures my
name is Sumi Terry I previously served
in the U.S government a long time CIA
officer and also at the National
Security Council
North Korea in the aftermath of the
Korean War actually was better off
economically than South Korea but in the
70s its economy started performing very
poorly and after the fall of the Soviet
Union in the early 1990s it really
suffered economically so there is no
other way to really make money for North
Korea other than to turn to illicit
activities according to the UN and
outside analysts Kim's regime sells
weapons on the black market uses its
diplomats to move illegal drugs like
methamphetamine they've trafficked in
counterfeit American dollars fake Viagra
[Music]
foreign
countries like Iran and Syria and even
pirated DVDs and pornography
[Music]
um
your activity is the greater is your
demand for interaction with the local
organized crime so say
drugs I don't think that North Koreans
has ever sold drugs themselves they
reach local criminal groups and sell the
drugs through them my name is Andrew
lenkov I've been doing North Korea since
1984 essentially visited many times
sometimes have been blacklisted
sometimes not essentially studied how
North Koreans reinvented capitalism in
the last 30 years
imagine you have a mission
your missile Engineers asked you to get
some equipment do you expect you to fly
to any country and you know just go to a
missile Factory not going to work
so the only way is to again rely on
people who for a good commission are
ready to do pretty much everything that
is Criminal gangs this historic
relationship between North Korea and
East Asian organized crime groups is
crucially important to understanding how
Pyongyang reacted to the oil cap imposed
by the UN
[Music]
Minister and I have talked about the
importance of full implementation of
resolution 1718 North Korea's number one
goal is regime survival and for that
regime survival they have to have a
strong military and part of having
strong military is also building nuclear
weapons program
they will be met
with fire and fury
like the world has never seen the Hope
Was That by putting a lot of pressure
through sanctions of North Korea that it
will lead to North Korea giving up
nuclear weapons program of course that
didn't happen
foreign
[Music]
is that North Korea doesn't have oil
so every drop of oil consumed in North
Korea is important you need oil to
move your vehicles
and if your vehicles are not moving
your soldiers will not get ammunition
and ballistic missiles will not fly is
North Korea's oil tankers they
previously used to travel to China they
travel to Russia to pick up refined
petroleum diesel gasoline
but after 2017 sanctions ramped up
you've had quite a number of UN member
states sending Patrol aircraft to
document all the ship to ship transfers
that involved either North Korean
tankers or vessels that had already been
designated for an assets freeze or a
global Port Entry ban by the security
Council some people were designated by
the UN others are now wanted for money
laundering there have been some arrests
a few suicides and a lot of those people
who were providing them oil ultimately
got burned
it became more difficult for North Korea
to input all around that time North
Korea has had to adapt and what are you
left with you're really left with groups
that have a high appetite for doing
illegal things and who have a successful
track record of not only conducting
activities that were against the law but
successfully laundering those funds and
staying at large and indeed flourishing
and who are those people well it's
organized crime groups such as the
Triads
[Music]
in Hong Kong are the local Triads which
have always been quite powerful a great
we need to be engaged in say all kinds
of trade including oil trade for the
North Koreans ship to ship transfers and
whichever these are the groups that
those people will team up with because
they provide protection and they can
also physically intimidate the captains
of ships and the crew of vessels because
if you talk to the authorities if you
turn an informant you really have to
think about the consequences of that not
only does North Korea have long-standing
ties to these organized criminal groups
but we know that these groups are also
deeply embedded in an illicit East Asian
oil trade that market is a multi-billion
Dollar business huge volumes of oil are
smuggled annually into China and the
people that are responsible for
smuggling that oil make huge profits
many of the players involved are
originally from the mainland of China
and these connections were established
with the North Koreans long before the
sanctions were actually implemented by
the security Council
we believe some of the most important
tankers that have been going to North
Korea are operated by a network of
people that live and work in Hong Kong
with high level connections to organized
crimes the Triads it's some of the first
evidence that's really ever been put out
into the open sources that's whatever
really showed this and how it works in
detail
[Music]
my name is Aaron Arnold I'm a senior
fellow at the Royal United Services
Institute I'm a former US member on the
UN panel of experts we often found that
North Korea would rely heavily on
jurisdictions like Hong Kong to
facilitate its sanctions of Asian
activities Hong Kong's domestic rules
and regulations offer a level of privacy
to North Korea that allows it to hide
its activities the people who we believe
own and operate the Unica and we suspect
a number of other tankers that have been
delivering oil to North Korea a Hong
Kong Nationals including one named Gary
tow
[Music]
we visited his offices in the golden
Financial Center in Kowloon Bay it's a
pretty normal office block Gary tow as
well as being on documents for the
ownership of the Unica The Vessel
delivering oil to North Korea he also
runs one of Hong Kong's largest gold
trading shops and outfits it's very much
a normal part of you know the business
district over there so he otherwise
appears to be a legitimate businessman
that shop and that entity in Hong Kong
has until recently been called Sun gold
holding it was We Believe intimately
connected to the Sun City Group the Sun
City group was at the time Asia's
largest casino and junket operator it
had been in the gambling business for a
very long time and it was operated by
people who were arrested in China and
are alleged to be high-level members of
the Triads Sun City was headed up by a
man called Alvin Chao and Alvin Chao is
pretty much notorious not only in Hong
Kong but also within all of Asia because
law enforcement have been looking at his
companies and how they operate Macau
Tycoon Alvin Chao has been arrested
after the authorities in the mainland
city issued an arrest warrant for him
the businessman is accused of running
illegal cross-border gambling rings
[Music]
it's a really effective way of mixing
legitimate money with illegitimate money
and it makes it very difficult if not
impossible for banks to identify the
real source of funds
[Music]
or one of the most famous gangsters in
Asia broken tooth basically notorious
for his role as being involved in the
14k Triad the same group that Alvin Chao
is also accused of being a member of
photographs from social occasions and
important business occasions
also demonstrate this quite close link
between Gary Tow and Alvin Chow
[Music]
regularly we find pictures of Gary tow
at events with other senior members of
the Sun City Group
people such as Cheng Ting Kong who's
been identified by the Australian
authorities that's involved in
high-level money laundering and drug
smuggling
my name is Sharon Ingrid quark and my
research area is trust society and I
started during research since my PhD
back in Hong Kong
there are three key track societies
operating in Hong Kong day 14k
um sunny on and also Wars and War their
operations are fairly vast and quite
geographically spread across Asia they
still do what we call the traditional
Triad businesses like you know sex
industry and also illegal gambling but
in addition to that there are quite a
number of legitimate business that they
do and Triads are also known for their
use of violence and that violence has
been helpful for some Casino operators
in order to enforce debts Sun City group
has closed all of its VIP gaming rooms
in Macau after the arrest of its CEO
what we found again and again were
connections to Sun City connections to
the organized crime groups to the people
in the casinos the Sun City group was
moving huge volumes of money out of
China into Macau and even further afield
gambling is illegal in China so it's
inevitable for them to use the illegal
channel to take the money out from China
Sun City was you know on paper basically
a gambling promoter but it was so much
more than that not only did it have
these listed companies it also had these
other networks of businesses across Asia
people who talk about Sun City and law
enforcement in the region in fact
characterized it more as a pan-Asian
underground bank which allowed the flows
of both legal and illicit money across
the region
the underground Financial networks such
as those who were operated by Sun City
are ultimately key to North Korea's
abilities to operate abroad
oftentimes North Korea will seek out
jurisdictions that have secrecy laws
that afford the country to hide its
identity so that it can repatriate that
illicit Revenue to support the regime's
nuclear weapons and ballistic missile
program
so the ability to launder money the
ability to move money through the
International Financial system without
being detected it's critical for North
Korea's abilities to continue building
its weapons program
[Music]
over the course of our investigation we
also discovered a connection between Sun
City group and an Emma Gray family in
Macau
the patriarch of the family was called
sun chanpan on Defector testimony an
official records suggests this man
Sunshine pan was dispatched in the 1950s
by North Korea to Macau as an agent
charged with raising money for the
regime
Sunshine pan was the head of the song
family that has since then established a
wide range of companies in Macau and
further afield these companies We
Believe were paying for the oil that was
being shipped to North Korea through the
International Financial system that
provided a Lifeline for Pyongyang
so the only place where a North Korean
Merchant acting on their orders from the
state or a spy could go to meet somebody
and do it more or less unnoticed it was
Macau
and in the North Korean intelligence
Services Macau was a dream job
um
foreign
a lot of these people at the heart of
this network have been operating in Hong
Kong and Macau for a long time we
believe one of the most important
individuals is a person named Sun tit
fam according to family sources suntit
fan is the grandchild of the original
patriarch that went to Macau
and he's been in business with a number
of people who are alleged to be Triads
and others who are closely connected to
identified Triads he's on documents
alongside me think the owner of the
rugion Corp that's been allegedly
involved in smuggling narcotics
yoga
so
um
so Sunset fan is a key part of this
story but not only does he connect to
the North Korean intelligence operations
into those smuggling operations he's
well known for driving a racing car in
races that were sponsored by Sun City
is he operated a company in conjunction
with Alvin Chao called the sun
international automobile company
he had a shop front in Macau where it's
all Ferraris Lamborghinis and arranged
by the luxury cars
[Music]
foreign
we still don't have every last piece of
the puzzle but until now no one has been
able to stitch together such a detailed
picture of these Networks
so what we have here we think is a
person intimately connected to North
Korea's intelligence apparatus abroad in
business with Alvin Chao and the Sun
City Group an Alvin child and the Sun
City Group were also ultimately
connected to the modern day oil
smuggling operations to North Korea
through a number of Hong Kong Nationals
including Gary toad
[Music]
this race is a much bigger question
which is about China why does China seem
to allow this kind of criminal activity
to go on under its nose given that
Beijing itself has signed up to these
sanctions
China's overwhelming antipathy towards
the United States and by extension many
of the other Western Powers has drawn it
into close relationships with countries
that are engaging in organized crime or
are regarded by the West as
International pariahs when I was on the
U.N panel of experts we would often
notify China potential breaches of the
sanctions regime unfortunately in their
jurisdiction this includes things like
ship to ship transfers and it was common
to not receive a response from China a
lot of the tankers continue to take Safe
Haven in Chinese Waters a lot of these
networks continue to move money through
the International Financial system but
the starting off point an idios Chinese
banks that hold accounts secretly
controlled by North Koreans so the North
Koreans have a Lifeline North Korea
represents a real conundrum for China on
the one hand China fought with North
Korea in the Korean war in the 1950s and
North Korea shares a border with China
but on the other hand North Korea's
nuclear missiles are seen by Beijing as
The crucial pretext that allows America
to maintain its aggressive forward
posture in Asia
in 2017 China and Russia were able to
cooperate in imposing the oil cap on
North Korea but now they are pushing not
only to alleviate sanctions on North
Korea but they've actually been trying
to publicly excuse and justify North
Korea's more aggressive behavior since
Russia's invasion of Ukraine we know
North Korea has a relationship with
Russia supplying artillery and other
weapons in return for Russia not
implementing sanctions and potentially
helping out this cash-strapped regime
with cash or fuel
China was quite willing until recently
to calculate with the United States but
is an ancient history now the reality is
that those who Shield the dprk from the
consequences of its exclatory missile
tests put the Asian region an entire
world at risk of conflict
it's a kind of full-scale call for Visa
United States
creating potential for instability near
the airports North Korea to be afloat
they need Korean Peninsula to be stable
and divided foreign
of North Korea's trade is with China if
China really wanted to cut off trade cut
off oil called a fuel cut off supplies
food
they can do that but of course China is
not willing to do that
um
[Music]
thank you
it's exceedingly unlikely that Kim
Jong-un will ever give up nuclear
weapons and we've tried almost
everything short of military conflict
from bilateral negotiations to
multilateral negotiations to maximum
pressure to Symmetry and diplomacy and
yet we are here where North Korea has up
to 60 nuclear warheads
yes
[Music]
the missile and nuclear development
these programs themselves are already
concerned for Japan because it's just
neighboring country any failure of the
test or any fall of the debris could
cause a serious damage to Japan
just imagine who wants your kids to tell
this is a missile alert anytime if you
hear this you have to find the
underground shelter who wants to you
know let their life like that in any
area of the world look back in the 1980s
they were seen as a joke but what did
happen to the ruling Elite of other
communist countries
you know they are in the previous
bin of History
but no scary is still run by the second
and third generation of the same unit
and likely to be run eventually by the
fourth generation as well
[Music]
but of course this story is about much
more than just North Korea itself I
don't think it's right to blame just
China and Russia for the weaknesses in
the sanctions regime you will see
British criminals French criminals
German criminals teaming up with the
North Koreans where they felt they could
make a buck including White Collar
criminals
so when we see like a ship to ship
transfer that unfolds what's behind that
is not just one point of failure but a
whole series of failures it's not just
let's say the government's
responsibility for not seizing the the
ship or preventing from happening but
it's the bank that has failed in its due
diligence it's the insurance company
that has failed to collect the proper
documentation it's the ship registry
that maybe didn't peek behind the
curtain a little bit more so there's
this entire chain then that's required
for Effective sanctions implementation
the real problems often lie with these
so-called Gatekeepers the lawyers and
the accountants that set up shell
companies and special purpose vehicles
that enable funds to be transferred
relatively anonymously North Korea's
sanctioned evasion activities are not
only happening in Asia but Africa Middle
Eastern Area or Latin Americas because
North Korean activities can be easily
under the radar of the authorities of
these countries
[Music]
foreign
is that the weapons program keeps going
the nuclear program keeps going it
doesn't Abate and so we need to step the
pressure back up we should recognize
globally that this is now an organized
crime problem and we should try and
diffuse some of the national tensions
and the blame game around sanctions and
encourage international law enforcement
cooperation
based on solid criminal charges that
would result in convictions to send a
very clear message to certain
high-profile individuals
who
is
Western countries could do a lot more at
the moment the Unica continues to sail
to North Korea but the only countries to
have sanctioned it are the European
Union the United States has not
sanctioned it and critically the United
Nations not sanctioned it despite being
well aware of the fact that it continues
to deliver oil to North Korea
we think we should more aggressively
Target these networks and we should also
Target the supply chains that are
helping the Unica getting oil to North
Korea all of that could be done and
should be done
to get really truly effective action
it's going to be up to the law
enforcement agencies of particular
member States including the People's
Republic of China there's no question
that the central authority of Beijing
and of the Communist party is directed
to try to clean up this type of
institutionalized crime but it certainly
still exists and the question is will a
more opaque china such as I think we're
now going into create more Shadows more
nooks and crannies for members of
organized crime groups to thrive in the
issue of the operations of the Triads of
the Chinese organized crime groups is
not just a criminal issue it is a wider
strategic issue and it's something that
we should all take a lot more seriously
than we're currently doing now
when it comes to dealing with the holes
in the Global Financial system there is
lots that can be done to sanction
individuals companies middlemen even
catch and arrest criminals
but the brute fact is that sanctions
haven't worked
diplomacy is going nowhere
and North Korea responds very badly to
threats of force so when Kim Jong-un
appears with his young daughter
and sends the message to the world that
he's not going anywhere and neither has
nuclear weapons this raises the question
is this something that we're going to
have to learn to live with
thank you
[Music]